hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the most interesting but also
for some of us hard to accept claims
that's made by david hume
in his inquiry concerning human
understanding takes place
fairly early on in section 8
which is focused on his treatment of
necessity on the one hand meaning
all things have some sort of cause and
that we're all caught up in a
massive causal matrix and liberty or
or freedom of the will and so this has
to do with human actions
and motivations and whether those are
indeed entirely necessitated or whether
they're free
and hume will introduce this idea here
that's supposed to be shoring up the the
side of liberty
and it certainly does perform that
argumentative function within the work
so what is the
thing that he's saying here what is his
contention
he tells us that
it is universally acknowledged that
there is a great uniformity
among the actions of men in all nations
and
ages and that human nature remains still
the same in its principles and
operations
now that is indeed a big claim and a big
claim
on on two counts right one is just the
content of the claim
that there is this great uniformity
in human actions and
motivations and that that this runs
through
all nations all ages
and that human nature is basically the
same
everywhere you go that that's already a
really strong
substantive claim i i think
you could make some sort of case for it
along
human lines what i'm not sure that he
can actually
do is say that it's universally
acknowledged because what that would
seem to imply
is a canvassing of indeed all places
and times to find this universal
acknowledgement
if we weaken that claim to make it be
18th century
europeans or perhaps just british or
perhaps just
scots people are
generally saying that this is the case
okay that might be
plausible but hume is not actually
saying that his rhetoric
doesn't reflect that sort of weakening
of it and so that's something to keep
in mind where would the registering of
this universal acknowledgement
actually come from let's move on from
that
what would this actually mean he tells
us the same motives
always produce the same actions notice
the
always there he's asserting that this
happens
of necessity right the same events
follow from the same causes and then he
gives some examples
of how this works and and before we go
into that i should say that
hume actually does devote early on in
his career
a great amount of examination and
thought
to what we call the passions or the
emotions and how those work how those
function as motives and he he does in
you know
look at what other people before him had
to say about it and he produces a
quite interesting and novel theory of
his own about
the passions and and how they function
you you want to look at the treaties
on human nature for that so uh he goes
then he says ambition
avarice self-love vanity these are all
you know generally viewed as bad things
then he talks about good things
friendship generosity public spirit
these passions mixed in various degrees
and distributed through society
have been from the beginning of the
world and still are the source of
all the actions and enterprises which
have ever been observed among
mankind again a very strong claim
we can look at these basic emotional
states or drives or aff activities what
are we calling passions
and if we thoroughly understand those we
will be able to
understand you know what human nature
plays out
like within any society and he gives
the example of ancient greeks and romans
because of course you know in the west
that's that's what they were
largely focused on would you know the
sentiments inclinations and course of
life of the
greeks and romans study the tempering
actions of the french and english the
french and english are those that you
have ready at hand
and you can look at them and you can say
well you know
french and english people and presumably
other europeans
of this time behave this way we can
project that backwards
into ancient greece or ancient rome we
could say well if we've got similar
circumstances
people are going to behave in similar
ways so we can transfer these
observations from times and cultures to
others and then he he says as well that
you know since humans are the same in
all times and places
history informs us of nothing new or
strange in this particular
the only real use of history he says is
to discover the constant and universal
principles of human nature
by showing men in all varieties of
circumstances and situations
and we can also talk about
understanding in the present or in the
past
other cultures that were we're not
familiar with in the sense of having
direct experience with
we can surmise about ancient china that
the ancient chinese
were pretty much the same as you know
contemporary europeans
or if we want to talk about today if we
were using hume contemporary americans
or where wherever you're watching this
from right
and again that's a bit of a stretch
isn't it but hume is definitely
committed to this idea
he also talks about another way
in which we acquire knowledge
of human nature he tells us the benefit
of that experience acquired by
long life and a variety of business and
company so living for a long time means
that you get to
observe over the course of a lifetime
presuming of course that you're a good
observer presuming of course
that you're not some ideologue who
thinks they already know everything and
you know that you're not
led astray by some some problem
you know that you actually are paying
attention to what's going on going on
around you
so you know hume wouldn't apply this say
to drug addicts
they're probably even if they live a
long time probably
not going to be great judges of human
nature nor people who are
liable to what hume in his time called
fanaticism
and what we would today call you know
extreme partisanship or you know being
being a warrior in the culture wars or
something like that
so you know there's something to that if
you live for
for quite a while you do learn things
right if you're paying attention and
then a variety of business
and company so this is kind of important
too
a variety of business and company be
spending time with
with different people not just hanging
out not just
you know finding the people who you went
to high school with and hanging out with
them
at the bar until you're 80 years old or
you're talking about the glory days
actually meeting new people going around
and finding out what they
they think business your occupations you
learn
things through the engagements that you
have
with the rest of the world so hume says
that there is a kind of benefit
of this he says that it instructs us in
the principles of human nature
and it regulates our future conduct as
well as speculation
by means of this guide this is a
wonderful line
we mount up to the knowledge of men's
inclinations
and motives now notice he gets a bit
more descriptive here
from not just their actions
but expressions and even gestures
so you know on your first job maybe you
don't really understand
how things work and you misinterpret
what people
are saying or doing but after you've
been in it for a while you can
figure out what their inclinations and
motives are from the way that they look
at you
or the the way that they gesture or the
tone of voice
not just their actions themselves
so this also he says uh
general observations treasured up by a
course of experience
give us the clue of human nature and
teach us to unravel
all of its intricacies now it's
important that he's talking about
unraveling these intricacies given the
next things that he's going to say
because he's going to bring up two
possible sets of objections to this
great uniformity of human nature
one of them is well wait a second what
about the differences that we do observe
between different people and different
peoples
different groups different communities
different cultures
different civilizations even we see that
that's the case
so if human nature is the same shouldn't
it all be
similar in in you know doing exactly the
same sort of thing and he says no no no
we can deal with with this the first
thing that we need to know is he says
we must not expect this uniformity of
human action should be carried to such a
length
such that all men in the same
circumstances will act precisely
in the same manner without making any
allowance for diversity diversity of
what
characters prejudices and opinions
he says from observing the variety of
conduct in different people were enabled
to form a greater variety of maxims
which however still suppose a degree of
uniformity and
regularity so maxims are rules that we
use
in order to figure out what's coming
next or to guide our action
so you know if we say everybody's out
for themselves that's that's a maxim
right
and that's that's a maxim that probably
is pretty easy to refute
just by finding a person who's not just
out for themselves but is publicly
minded right
so we we need a wider variety of maxims
but they're
all still within the same basic system
he says
so what causes these differences
he says are the manners of people
different in different ages and
countries
well we learn the great force of custom
and education which mold the human mind
from its infancy and form it into a
fixed and established character so maybe
the greeks and romans
are in fact different i mean the romans
felt themselves different from the
greeks
and the greeks felt themselves different
from the romans
right and so that would be attributable
to custom
and education even with among the greeks
we could you know talk about the
age-old difference between the spartans
and the athenians and there's so many
others as well that we could talk about
uh but that's the one that all every
textbook likes to to discuss
right you know the aristocratic war-like
spartans and the democratic
although there were aristocrats there as
well and
war-like just not war-like in the same
way that the spartans were
athenians i mean the athenians were
viewed as sort of the evil empire of the
time
and the spartans were viewed as the
liberators during the peloponnesian war
by some of the greeks
so all of that has to do with the force
of custom and education people are
brought up differently with different
ideas and those affect their
their motivations and their conduct he
also says
listen there's there's different uh
characters
of for example the sexes he says
is the behavior and conduct of the one
sex very unlike that of the other it's
thence we become acquainted with the
different characters
nature has impressed upon the sexes and
which she preserves with constancy and
regularity so
you know nowadays we called hume a
gender essentialist right
and and it was quite common in his time
to do so that's why mary wollstonecraft
writing not long
after hume would say hey hey a lot of
these things that you're saying
are different characters of sexes coming
from nature are
actually coming from the force of custom
and education and demonstrating that in
her own
life different ages of life
you know we don't expect the same
motivations and behavior from a 70 year
old
as we do from a seven-year-old hopefully
not unless the 70 year old has gone
senile
right and thinks that they're a child
again
and we similarly expect that as a person
ages
and matures there's some things they're
going to leave behind some perspectives
some motivations
and there's others that they're going to
pick up some of those uh could in fact
be
attributable to nature think about what
puberty does to us
right suddenly you're you know not quite
as interested in candy and you're way
more interested
in whatever sex you're you're attracted
to
and you know we can even talk about
individual
characters having a certain kind of
regularities as the characters peculiar
to each individual
have a uniformity in their influence
otherwise our acquaintance with the
persons
and our observations of their conduct
could never teach us their dispositions
or serve to direct
our behavior with respect to them so you
know hume is saying
we we can still say that human nature is
essentially
uh universal constant the same
everywhere it's just going to be way
more
complicated and there will be all these
other things sort of
intervening another issue that he brings
up that
you know he really does have to address
well what about
actions that are out of character when a
person does things you're like
what's going on there that that doesn't
seem to be
the way that uh we expect this this
person over here
to behave and he says
if we could know what judgment should be
formed of such
irregular and extraordinary actions we
can consider the sentiments commonly
entertained with regard to those
irregular events which appear in the
course of nature
all causes are not conjoined to their
usual effects with
like uniformity right people are
complex he says they p people who
understand the human body
realize that it is a mighty complicated
machine that many secret powers lurk in
it which are all together
beyond our comprehension and that to us
it must appear very uncertain in its
operations and irregular and then he
says the philosopher
if the philosopher wants to be
consistent must apply the same reasoning
to the actions and volitions of
intelligent agents
we will do things every once in a while
that appear to be out of character
they are actually caused according to
hume
and they're following from human nature
it's just that we don't actually see
what's going on so we're surprised by it
he says the most irregular and
unexpected resolutions
can be accounted for by those who know
every particular circumstance of their
character and situation
so a person of obliging disposition
gives a peevish
answer right nowadays we'd say a person
who's nice acts like a jerk
and we say oh what's going on there well
there's some sort of hidden cause
and if you knew the person well enough
you would be able to discern
why they're behaving in that way
a stupid fellow discovers an uncommon
alacrity in his character right so
stupid person
somebody who doesn't pay attention to
things
manages to get things right um
so turns out he's met with a sudden
piece of good fortune
and he says even when an action it
sometimes happens cannot be particularly
accounted for
either by the person himself or by
others we know
in general that the characters of men
are to a certain degree inconstant
and irregular it reminds me of
aristotle's dictum
in nick of mccain ethics book three
about the person who is consistently
inconsistent right so so you know that
that
is able to you could say address
this this problem of out of character
actions
there's some sort of cause and that
produces the exception
now before we end this we should think
about why does hume
need to say this why why is he so firmly
committed
to this doctrine is this just something
that he
wants to hold on to because he's really
attracted to this idea
i would say no and this goes a little
bit beyond the text
once you actually start to
say that that cause and effect and hume
thinks that we know everything about the
world that's that's not just coming from
our senses and memory
through cause and effect and the
inference of cause and effect
once you start to take that away and
you've got
human beings in the world by take it
away i mean to say that there is no such
thing as like absolute causality
out there as far as we know right we
just observe
this this thing happening and our minds
work that way
then if people were fundamentally
different from each other
we really wouldn't be able to understand
human actions and motivations
this would be a big problem this would
mean that
it could in fact be the case that
foreign cultures are
entirely foreign or alien to us and we
could never
understand them hume doesn't want to say
that so
hume needs to to make this this sort of
assertion and these are the reasons the
arguments by which he makes
and defends this position
you